the crews are heading into danger and
almost certain whiteout they are trying
to contain fires which are moving with a
frightening ferocity thing is this area
doesn't even look as dry as other areas
and yet it's going up in flames
they're working in stifling heat with
temperatures well over 40 degrees
Celsius he just dropped three and a half
thousand litres then it barely made a
difference the crews have to repeatedly
refill and still the fires keep coming
Batemans Bay is a popular tourist
destination but the most intense blazes
here have turned the skies a bright
amber the crews are maneuvering near
blind dropping what seems like trickles
of water in comparison to the giant bush
fires
you can hardly make them out in this
suffocating smoke fog as they try and
try to stop the fires relentless and
unpredictable move towards homes and
farms pilot James Williams is only 26
but he's clocked up a staggering number
of hours in his short career battling
the bush the damage is extensive make
you feel sad seeing that James but with
winds of more than 80 miles per hour the
firefighting authorities simply can't
keep up with the breakouts this is what
the New South Wales fire authorities are
having to put up with these fires start
from nowhere and they've gone and spread
incredibly quickly very difficult for
them to stop it but while bush fires
rage in some areas others just a few
miles away as spared this time and
they're doing all they can to try to
look after the starving and displaced
wildlife dozens have been looked after
here for the past six weeks as the fires
rampage through their Bush home the
family is intent on saving lives both
animal and human four of them are
volunteer firefighters doing one of the
most dangerous jobs in the state right
now and mum Carrie and the two youngest
want to join up as well with the climate
change we'll need more firefighters it's
going to become more of a the sub
Early's hit are now the fires going to
come to
yeah we've got a fire down at Mary Beach
so that'll be heading this way now
somebody has to do it's a community of
duty yeah we kind of just stand and
watch because then but first they have
to survive the fires circling them and
causing so much smoke the Sun
disappeared mid-afternoon hundreds of
homes have lost power and there are food
shortages with deliveries halted through
road closures and businesses put in
jeopardy they impacted big time and it
probably might recover for a while and
the fires are still not under control
Alex Crawford sky news in New South
Wales Australia